ich habe auf 1 mein stein schwert ich
habe nur eine waffe auf zwei beinen
bogen auf drei meine angel
ceausescus und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video büro ein paar von euch
wir müssen jetzt mal kurz eine reise
zurück in die zeit machen ein paar von
euch kennen ja bestimmt noch das format
zuschauer überrascht das habe ich damals
gemacht wenn ich auf meinen ts gegangen
wenn er in irgendwelche random lobbys
gegangen und habe mit den leuten länder
aufgenommen
ich dachte heute das machen wir nochmal
aber heute kombinieren wir das mit dem
ixs wie sie wieder wenn das format luca
sagt carney sagt ihr wisst was ich meine
also das format wo andere leute mir
vorschreiben was ich machen soll
heute sind es aber keine andere youtuber
weil das ist doch unfair wenn nur
youtube wählen dürfen heute sind meine
zuschauer von meinem ts und wir gehen
zwar eine lobby da und gucken mal ob die
überhaupt ready sind hier oben haben wir
doch direkt was hallo ich habe über voll
auf euch geplant und zwar passt auf ihr
kennt ja vielleicht so diese luca sagt
videos die schon mal gemacht hat ich
dachte mir ich bring das format zurück
aber kombiniert mit den zuschauer
überrascht von damals deswegen habt ihr
jetzt vorausgesetzt ihr habt lust die
gelegenheit eine joggingrunde lang
miralles vorzuschreiben was ihr wollt
das hat ihr davon
so leute wir sind jetzt in der runde
zusammen mit jason king pkw und kombi
das sind die drei jungs die wir heute
hier bis in das leben schwer machen
werden
respekt gerade hier sieht man nur deinen
eck besser als der gut ich bin bombis
111 und ihr habt zusammen heute fünf
befehle die mir geben können über die
ganze runde verteilt und ich muss alles
machen was ihr sagt ihr müsst euch aber
gut einteilen
die anderen beiden auch noch am leben
jason soll
ich hab dann umgebracht dieser sollte
nicht zu lange warten aber sollte jetzt
auch nicht auch nicht unnötig oder
pulver verschießen
also ihr habt halten nur die 5 sie habe
ein das heißt ihr könnt auch mal einen
verschießen alle müssen vorsichtig sein
damit denn wenn die fünf vorbei sind
dann kann ich hier ganz unbeschwert
spielen und das ziel ist natürlich leute
weil die jetzt gerade von zu hause aus
zu schauen dass das ding gewinnen
selbstverständlich ok modul sechs soweit
noch keine challenge.de bei dem ein
kleines secret vorstellen griffigen
rauch ist ein boxer der sämtliche jumps
in einem video vorgestellt hat also seht
ihr da unten war die eine kiste hier
zeigt der bbe geräumt und da oben ist
noch einer
zwei kisten dem modul wir haben schon
gar nicht so schlecht das equipment
übrigens nicht wett demnächst ein neues
projekt starten und in dem projekt könnt
ihr auch auftauchen das funktioniert
folgendermaßen ich habe in der
beschreibung ist der erste link von oben
ein google vom verlinkt heißt es in
formular was ja ausführlich und was ich
brauche von euch für dieses neue format
sind einfach lustige seltsame komische
videos das ist alles wenn ihr irgendwo
video hat wo ihr euch denkt okay was ist
das das ist so merkwürdig aber es ist
irgendwie witzig und es könnte ganz
lustig aussehen wenn es gesicht das
anschauen dazu reagiert dann klickt auf
den link in der beschreibung und füllt
das formular austrag den youtube link
ein und dann stehen die chancen gut dass
ihr in dem neuen format mit dabei sein
und natürlich
die person deren einsendung dann kommt
auch namentlich erwähnt also genauso wie
ein hacker schon bereit so viel dann von
meiner seite
ansonsten bin ich hier schon im modul
acht leute lasst euch zeit wohl kaum am
ende bin ich dann einfach die runde
sitzt niemand etwas gesagt das können
wir auch machen
also ich freue mich ich freue mich für
das leben dann so leicht macht der bank
ist ein
das ist erlaubt aber ich sage ich ich
darf euch auch nicht ausreden also eher
kommen dann haben wir das was auf slot 1
2 und 3 ist raus
ich habe auf 1 meilenstein schwert ich
habe nur eine waffe auf zweimal bogen
auf drei meine angel wird junge ok alles
da suche man ok alles weg in den abgrund
jawohl nächste kiste geöffnet ersten
stein schon drin
jawohl der liebe gott hat mich lieb
alter dankeschön
ich bin nicht mehr religiös aber in
solchen momenten
jawohl das ist nicht so gut hier ist das
reich handys ist mega tricky mann
ich würde euch diese diesen abschnitt
teilweise schaffe ich den volk muss
jetzt einfach nach links durch springen
wieder ein linkes bild fand einfach
direkt auf diesem blog drauf gehen
können
du kannst jetzt schon mal zurück bringen
da wo er ist auf fest oder einfach so
geht das
laumann ich bin so dumm ich dachte ich
muss hier rüber und dann hier irgendwie
so tricky um die ecke springen das sind
treue zuschauer leute obwohl sie euch
das leben schwer machen können geben
sich trotzdem noch tipps die so können
wir vielleicht noch die nächste kiste
mitnehmen da wohl und habe hier diesen
in kambodscha wo die kiste komme auf
jeden fall noch mitnehmen
okay ich habe eine suppe ich habe drei
äpfel ich hatte einen changes bett und
ich habe drei pfeile dann nehme ich die
10 3 als eine sache eigentlich nicht
die 12 und ein teilnehmer mit
dann hab einfach danke schön leute danke
dafür
nein dort finde ich wünsche ich finde
ich finde ich nicht ja wort [ __ ] to be a
nice wie immer gelten hier die anmerkung
das ist jetzt keine nachvertonung für
pornofilme sondern wieder mal die
us-kirche jump league spielt und dabei
komische geräusche von sich gibt nein
als ob die runde endet ich schwöre ich
hätte jetzt gekündigt alles klar
heckmann schneider
daraus geht es mir machen
an sich ist auch stein schon erlaubt
wo kommt er her okay von dem was ich hab
meine lieder weggeworfen wo ist man
leder wieder hinten leute ich das glück
gehabt ok alles klar sich ganz machen
challenge drei von fünf und ich mache
mir schnell mal kleines fns geht es wird
jetzt auch schon recht einfach schon ein
leben verloren
noch keine person gekillt brockmann
wittich gegen herunter fak der eine gilt
die gegend ok herr was ist los mit ihm
was geben sie den wilsmann ich schwöre
euch die spiele nicht lädiert was ist
los man hier noch an dem ich meine wir
können ja gern noch hinzufügen dass ab
jetzt auch nichts anderes wir nutzen das
aus erschwert um jemanden irgendwie
scheint hinzuzufügen also so etwas wie
angel oder bogen wir auch nicht erlaubt
okay was mit es ist auch verboten
die legen die ganze zeit so castete
gegen was soll ich da machen gute tonnen
okay ich hab einen zweiten vorteil gegen
ihn
das könnte klappen das kann ich als
kandidaten das klappt
damit habe ich klar haben wir vier
eingesetzt viel eingesetzt also ihr
hatten meine neffen es auch verboten bis
ich schmeiße vor dem brunnen
wisst ihr was scheiß drauf hier kommt
sagt karsten broockmann eröffnet hatte
jetzt hat er einen vorteil denn holz
jaja aber den hole ich manchmal wenn er
jetzt nicht zu dem anderen handelt wenn
er sie jetzt aber umdreht um mich zu dem
anderen eine dann habe ich ein richtiges
problem bekommen abkürzen jawoll
nein also die anderen ein und es hat
gewonnen
thomas jura
t
wir haben nur vier eingelöst um
tatsächlich nur mit vier geschafft zu
verhindern dass ich die runde gewinne
doch ich glaube tief vergraben habe ich
verdammt wurde aber teilweise hänge ich
mich auf diesem springseil was heute
gekommen ist kann man auch noch auf
jeden fall ist eine normale reaktion
aber abschließend danke schon noch mal
an jason king gp ferrari und kombi dass
ihr dabei war denkt thanks und ja für
alle die das video sehen
bis zum nächsten mal wenn ihr noch mal
so eine zuschauer überrascht zuschauer
sagen sagt sagt folge haben wollen dann
schreibt uns in die kommentare
dann machen wir das gern noch mal
ansonsten sehen wir uns bald mit der
neuen serie wieder wie gesagt unbedingt
bei dir lustige videos habt klick den
link in der beschreibung und schickt mir
die links dazu
dann wird die welt ein besserer ort
alles klar gut bis zum nächsten mal
j